obviously what's happening in Turkey is
just an awful awful tragedy and you know
the scale of human loss is something
that is hard to comprehend I spoke to
president erdogan of Turkey just the
other day to express our solidarity and
sympathy and make sure that we provide
all the support we can as a country
people should know that we sent very
quickly 77 specialist search and rescue
teams who arrived a couple of days ago
started work straight away they're
already making a difference on the
ground and of course all ministers are
in touch with their counterparts and to
continue providing all assistance and
the government has said it will match
five million pounds in fact of
everyone's contribution to the deck
appeal so please if you give generously
know the government will match that and
we can get that extra support to the
people on the ground who need it